What is the impact of finding your WHY?
So, I can tell you what I went through
which is what set me on the journey
to sharing the message of the WHY
and helping people find theirs.
A WHY is like a compass direction
it tells you where you're going.
We can live our lives by accident
which is kind of like getting in a ship
and just sailing
or just getting in a car
and just driving.
You'll absolutely see some amazing things
you'll stumble upon some amazing experiences
but you don't really have a sense of where you're going
any sort of direction.
In other words
what's it all for?
What the WHY does is it provides a path.
It provides a map or a compass.
So you will still have some of those
amazing experiences
but now they have value and worth
and they're taking you towards something else
it's a journey toward something.
When I learned my WHY
I had a tremendous calm come over me.
My confidence grew.
A sense that my life had more meaning
than I thought it had before.
And I had now the choice
a new way of viewing decisions
a filter
through which to make decisions.
Now I ask myself
does this help advance my WHY or not?
Does this help me stay on the path that
I'm supposed to be on?
Or is this going to be a random adventure?
So the WHY provides
focus, direction, meaning
and confidence.